hey phil how you doing i'm doing very
well thanks how are you
i'm good so i have to tell you i'm so
excited that
jamie's in season two with everything
how it wrapped up in season one i wasn't
sure if he was gonna be back did you
always know this character would be back
hoped
i hoped we had some conversations before
but um
yeah i i you know it's
i didn't really know in what capacity
but i was
uh yeah i was told that that jamie would
be back in some way
shape or form yeah thankfully
thankfully yeah well we had so much fun
watching jamie season one i mean this is
a character that is so
like we have this love hate for this
character um
so what can we expect from him in season
two
you know i think i think what we see is
a continuation of that emotional journey
that he was on
um you know we we find jamie
um in a in an interesting form
at the start of season two we see him uh
maybe wearing fewer clothes than he
maybe uh was before
and uh yeah he's gone down a slightly
different path
and i think that it's you know there's
there's retribution to be found
for him going forward uh he
he jamie has at some point learned how
to say sorry he's learned that word
and i think that he's starting to use it
it's like you know he's just like
spraying it around to people
um and he's he's trying it on and he's
trying this like
you know he's trying on his emotional
big boy shoes
and uh i think the lessons that jet that
jamie has learned through
through ted and also through you know
all members of the team
and through keely as well um
he's you know he's continuing on that
journey and he's trying i think that
that's one of the great things i love
about jamie is that
we see someone you know pretty
reluctantly
but he's still trying and i think that
you know he's turning up he's doing the
work
yeah and i think especially by the end
of the of season one like
the viewers fall in love with your
character like we we want more that's
why i'm like so happy and especially
when
the season two trailer came out i wasn't
sure so i'm just like super excited when
i saw the first few episodes
um did you know that this show was going
to be so well received by critics
and audiences i mean this show dominated
award season
we've been very lucky with it yeah uh
imagine if imagine if i was telling my
family i got this yeah i got this show
and it's going to be like
everyone's going to love it it's going
to be great no it's
not really imagine i'm sure that some
people do say that
it was think that i
i knew it was really great when i read
it and when i got involved in it i was
like this is this feels special feels
really like a a
special job but no way man i mean
we we it sounds overtly sort of
humble to say but i don't think anybody
really expected it
to kick off in the way that it has yeah
i'm sure that the
you know the people in charge hoped it
would but um
but yeah i think it really tapped into
something that people were needing
um contextually in the time that it came
out um a lot of people were
in lockdown um i think that people
needed to see
normal people being good and trying hard
and also you know people couldn't go out
and see people and each week they were
able to welcome
this family into their home um i've used
the family cliche
to hit the buzzer but you know i think
people were looking for that connection
throughout that time but but also out of
the context of when it is
i think that people love football and
people love
people being kind and trying and also
it's funny as well like it's a really
funny show
jason uh and and brendan hun
are really really funny people nick
muhammad i think is probably the
funniest person in the world
uh and we're very lucky that we got to
watch him i would completely agree with
all that and what was so fun about
season one two was watching
jamie and ted jamie's face looking
confused when ted would say these
like dad jokes and overly positive
things um did you ever have a hard time
staying in character when you were
around jason
yeah of course yeah i mean like the guy
is just super funny and also like
what what jason is really good at is
like um i think he calls it soloing
around the text where
uh you know he he's just like he's just
doing his thing
and he's rolling and like he's just
throwing this stuff out i'm like i don't
i don't know how i can't quite grasp how
he is as funny as he is but
i struggled with that but um
you know when you're really like really
digging your heels in trying to play
jamie you're like no okay come on come
on come on
but something that i just can't my trip
tonight is brett goldstein
i don't know what it is about him about
his stupid face
there's something about him that just it
just makes me crack up and i don't know
what it's like
we have so for some reason we have we're
so we're so close in all the scenes we
do we're like
this and i'm like i can't
i can't keep a straight face around you
yeah
stupid face this stupid stupid roy kent
face i love that so much well
congratulations on all the success on
this show and uh
yeah we only got the first couple of
episodes i can't wait to watch the rest
of the season i'm such a big fan
oh thanks mate that's really lovely to
hear thank you enjoy it enjoy
you